Chester and you were the heart of
Lincoln Park you rapping and Chester
singing it was a really just a unique
sound and then to lose that connection
with somebody has to blow your [__]
mind I I can't even imagine the pain you
were in I would be angry with him I
think there's I think there's points
when that that yeah there's points when
I felt that way I'm sure for other
people it was the same even fans too by
the way and that's natural that's normal
that's like one of the stages of grief
right that's anger's in there what is it
like to work with someone who suffers
from depression not only is it difficult
for him but at the time you don't even
understand the depths of it right that's
true actually that part is important to
say too because I None of nobody knew
the depths of it but did it scare you in
other words did you say to yourself at
that time no it was let me actually
let's go back to the beginning when I
met Chester I didn't know his stories as
I got to know him I would find myself
oftentimes saying that's
I've never heard such a crazy upbringing
like such a crazy childhood like running
wild like in the streets and and doing
hard drugs on the roof of his high
school just like completely like just
barely staying out of jail
and so different and that's what made
our Dynamic what it was it's like I
didn't but I didn't like that I felt
like I was an outsider because I was
like a mixed race kid that didn't have
like a community to belong to like I
didn't identify with I'm half Japanese I
didn't speak Japanese I don't look
Japanese the white kids thought I was
like obviously not white the the Latino
kids were like starting to speak to me
in Spanish I didn't speak any Spanish
like I just didn't have it was I was
always floating around and have like a
home but because he had his issues was
he a difficult guy to deal with the
whole time was it like oh gee no no
early day is more difficult because we
were still
we didn't know how it was going to go
like on the early days Hybrid Theory we
were still getting started and we'd have
we'd get a win here we'd get a loss
there we sent the song to the radio
they're playing it oh the show is going
to be a kind of a small show it's gonna
be hard to get there you're gonna have
to drive all night it's gonna be tough
you're going to be exhausted oh by the
way we all just got sick like it was
hard and so in the midst of all of that
having a guy who would sneak out he'd
just go missing
and come back obliterated that you
couldn't even talk to him he's just so
wasted
um but also funny you ever hear about
that or see that episode was that
Friends episode where they have the um
fun Bobby yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
fun Bobby's hilarious and fun everybody
loves him and then the second he gets
sober nobody likes him anymore there's
an element of Chester it was very fun
sometimes when he was that way and then
usually the next day it'd be like
so dark you just like he has he's super
hungover he's angry at everybody yelling
at everybody and you're kind of just
like just
let him you know
let's get to through the day did you
doubt it any time that like oh no
Chester's gone maybe I don't want to do
music anymore was there any of that yeah
of course 100 100 it's like for me it
just felt like too much
like to to get back on it and try and do
some version of music
and also be seen through the lens of
what had happened
yeah for that to be attached it was like
being a member of a club that I didn't
want to join
thank you